[Music]
you are watching the press preview
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
coming up we'll see what's making the
headlines with the chief leader writer
at the observer
sonia soda and the political journalist
isabel oakshot
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
england's first knockout victory over
germany in 55 years is on the front
of the metro with the paper proclaiming
that the jinx
is over the sun praises the sterling
work of the footballer who scored the
first goal hailing the end of what's
described as 55 years of hurt
by george we did it says the daily mail
the daily mirror declares that it's time
to dream
the express says scotland yard faces
urgent questions over why
officers witnesses witnessed professor
chris witte being attacked
but did not arrest those responsible
the telegraph says children from the
most deprived areas are hit hardest by
school self-isolation and the picture
there of harry kane
at the top the eye reports that the
vaccine task force is buying up stocks
as the nhs prepares for
a booster program in the autumn
and just some breaking news in we're
hearing that ukraine have won
so they will be the next opponent for
england and we're joined to take us
through the papers tonight by sonia soda
chief leader writer
at the observer and political journalist
isabelle oakshot welcome to you both
your reaction
to that first of all sonia ukraine it's
to be
well i have to say i didn't watch um the
whole match because i was preparing for
this
but i did have it on in the background
and i saw that a goal going
in the i think it was well first or
second minute of extra time three
minutes event
three minutes of extra time on the extra
time and ukraine got the goal in so
they did leave it until very the very
last minute
um but that is great for them and um
i think it's probably you know i think
england's prospects against either
ukraine or sweden
are probably quite half decent this
saturday so
um it's exciting looking forward to see
what happens then
and isabel starting with the metro the
jinx
it's all over can they go all the way
well he is hoping i mean every paper
tomorrow
covers this story of course on the front
pages with
huge degrees of enthusiasm and you know
i'm no great football fan but i think
all of us
can join in and feel seriously excited
by the result this evening and and just
a little bit optimistic maybe
yes i mean a lot a lot of them
emphasizing this this end of the the 55
year curse and that's what many were
saying seem to be
following england players around but
many of the players are simply too young
to
to be a part of that though aren't they
sonya so it's a it's a different era
it's totally a different era and um i
think you know obviously everyone
who supports england is absolutely
delighted uh tonight it was
a good really good match to watch but i
think there's probably some people who
are a bit surprised at the result as
well
um so um you know it's it's it's a i
guess it's just a very sort of pleasant
surprise
um you know germany i think were
probably thought to be the stronger team
going into it
uh but you know england were the ones
who went and scored 10
two goals and made the score two nil you
can probably tell
i'm not that expert at football so uh my
punditry is rather lacking here
isabelle's giggling at you let's test
her shall we
many saying that that germany wasn't
wasn't the team
of old that that perhaps you know we we
should fear that it was a different
ranking in terms of player quality that
played against england tonight
um if you're asking me for my expertise
on that you are totally asking the wrong
person
i am not even going to position myself
here as an even
even a mediocre football correspondent
sonia i was super impressed with your
fluency on this and i think back to
sonia on that one
it's not tennis back and forth
um well let's talk in general though
about how the newspapers are
covering um i mean it is just totally
jubilant isn't it every single
paper without fail i think
sonia yeah absolutely it's just a
massive deal isn't it when your national
team
gets through its first kind of knockout
match of the tournament
and um you know england's going to a
quarter
on saturday where it's got a fairly
decent glance
so i just think you know with everything
that's been going on at the moment
um you know when we look at covert
infection rates are
ticking up again it's just absolutely
brilliant to have something to celebrate
over the summer so
um yeah i think that's you know that and
that is the tone in which
every paper has covered it yeah and um
isabel that the
son winning i think with the the puns
55 years of hurt never stopped us
raheeming
degrown i thought that was a little bit
lame but there are some really um
fantastic images
uh in tomorrow's papers including lovely
pictures
of uh brigate middleton and her and um
and the number of royals looking really
great and enthusiastic
as they should and also scenes of utter
jubilation on the streets which are
bound to sort of reopen the debate about
the extent to which lockdown
restrictions are still meaningful in
terms of public
gatherings uh extraordinary scenes uh in
central london and i'm sure
up and down the country of people
celebrating and not really
paying any attention of course to to
social distancing
yeah you mentioned the royals and the
mail has a lovely picture of
prince george on on the front there
looking very smart
in his uh his suit and tie along with
the fans on that picture of um
um harry kane also
there and it was great to see see the
royals we saw um
prince william punching the air in
absolute delight didn't we did you see
that sonia
yeah i did um i guess yeah it's one of
those things that
everyone can get involved in really you
know whether you're a royal
or um you know i suppose whether you're
not i'm
yeah um yeah it's just and what's
interesting is actually wimbledon
also kicked off
you can as you can see my commentary is
struggling um
sorry go ahead some kind of you know
parody of you know
failed um commentators as they get asked
to talk about things that are totally
outside their comfort zone
can we move on at any point and agree
that the football's fab
and sonia and i are just not the people
to be talking about this
we will take you out of your misery and
move on it's just it's on every single
paper so
we kind of had to talk about it let's
move on to the eye
and jab stockpile to help uk live with
covid19 sonya take us into this story
um so this is uh the eye reporting um
what's looking forward to the vaccine
program um with what's
you know what's going to be happening
over the summer and into the autumn
and it talks about how the government is
stockpiling
a large number of jabs looking for the
autumn because we're all expecting there
to be a booster vaccination program
and in fact just this week the
government announced that it was going
to be
running a trial a booster trial it asks
for people who've had two
um astrazeneca jabs to register on the
nhs website if they're interested in
taking part in the trial
um and those people will be getting a
third booster jab a different jab so
pfizer or moderna
and that will be tested in time for um
autumn rollout so i think it's very
heartening to see
um that as you'd expect plans are being
made for the autumn
the testing is going on i expect
that from what we know so far the
emerging evidence about
mix and match strategies um it suggests
that actually
mixing different types of vaccines so
the adenovirus vaccine
which is the astrazeneca vaccine with
mrna vaccines like pfizer and moderna
can boost immunity even further so i
expect that's what we're going to be
seeing from the government um
and from the vaccine program this autumn
yeah it's about one of the things that
the article is um
pointing out is that they're saying the
transport secretary is downplaying hopes
that fully vaccinated holidaymakers
will be able to travel quarantine free
to amber list
countries um that will be a bit of a
blow to people because i think many
people are counting on that because the
government had
heavily hinted that that would be the
way forward
well i mean i think if they are counting
on it they're being pretty foolish
because unfortunately it's not just
up to us what we say and what we're
seeing is quite chaotic
scenes amongst europe's political
leaders about what their policy is going
to be
on this and the germans pushing for the
whole of europe to
ask us to quarantine when we arrive
whether we've had two vaccines or not
and then other countries saying no
actually we really want to welcome the
british we need their
holiday money so i think it's pretty
daft actually
to to plan with any type of confidence
any holiday
on the continent this summer it's just
going to be too
uncertain even if our own government can
decide what they want to do
things seem to be shifting very fast in
in the countries that we might want to
go to yes you're right
it's how we will be received by other
countries that is a very important
element as well let's take a quick look
at
the um metro and many people have seen
the
the footage awful footage disgraceful
footage of the professor chris witte
being
manhandled by um several yobs the
the pressure is now on on the met to
actually
get somebody for it
yeah i think anyone who's sort of seen
that footage will agree
how shocking it was and i think it's
just disgraceful that you can be
you know really look at somebody like
chris whitty um the amount of public
service he's given to this country
um since march last year and indeed
before that obviously as
the government's chief medical officer
um must have been working
all hours i've spoken to some of the
scientists
involved with um sage for example and
they have increasingly over the last
year
come under personal attack for example
on social media in a way that they just
would never have done before the
pandemic you know targeted by people who
disagree
with what the government's doing who are
you know spreading anti-vax conspiracy
theories
and i think the stuff on social media is
is frightening enough
you know some of them have been getting
threats um to them
and their family but this is just it
takes it on to a whole other level
it's a physical assault um you know it's
really it must have been so scary for
him um
and it's just unbelievable that we live
in a world where that can happen to you
as a result of the public service you've
done for this country so i think it
really does make you
worry actually about you know we see all
the sort of
polarized debate online about things
like
vaccines and the effectiveness of
vaccines um
and you know people arguing very
heatedly
um for forward against lockdowns but
it's really worrying when you see um you
know some of this stuff sort of
actually kind of happen like this in the
real world
isabel and sonia thank you very much for
the moment both of you we are going to
take a break and
coming up the educational divide
children in deprived areas are far more
likely
to be forced to self-isolate than
children in wealthier areas
stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me again
the chief leader writer at the observer
sonia soder and the political journalist
isabel oakshot welcome back to both of
you let's
take a look at the telegraph front page
and this is
the um cry to end the bubble system in
schools and
they're saying that isolation the
self-isolation that schools are being
forced to um put students in it's
hitting the poorest
pupils the hardest sonia
yes so um i think this will be affecting
a lot of parents up and down the country
actually i know
uh parents uh who are friends of mine
whose kids are at school
who have ended up having to self-isolate
because one child
in the bubble tests positive and then
the whole bubble has to self-isolate um
i think the point is that we're so far
into the pandemic now
we've got quite good testing systems in
place
so what experts mps are calling for
um and asking about is can we not have
better testing systems
in schools to reduce the number of
children having to self-isolate because
the amount of
school time that children can end up
missing is huge
as this telegraph story sets out it's
highest for children from
poorer areas who we know are the
children
from disadvantaged backgrounds who've
been most affected by the pandemic so
far
we know that the education gap is
getting wider so
um i think this is a really good kind of
um it's a good thing to be asking the
government because we know the
government has been
too slow to act on mitigating the impact
of the pandemic on children over the
last year
yes and isabella would obviously reduce
the the numbers of children being out of
school they've lost so much education
as it is and perfectly healthy children
are being forced to
to stay at home in great numbers
oh yeah i mean listen don't get me
started on this i have been banging on
about this for
about a month now i wrote about it for
the daily mail
last week and i think it's a huge issue
you know as a parent i have seen
the extent to which young children's
education
is being ridiculously and continually
disrupted
by these alerts when a pupil or a
teacher or somebody connected to the
school
supposedly tests positive or usually
they're almost
always asymptomatic and then dozens of
children
are sent home and it is absolutely awful
it's awful for children
it's awful for working parents and
by and large it is completely
unnecessary the figures on this
are extraordinary 385
000 children are not at school
because of these alerts and the vast
majority of those children
are totally healthy so this is a
nonsense it has to stop i have no idea
why it has taken anybody so long to wake
up to the fact
that this is such a pressing issue and i
really hope that the
government changes the guidance to
schools because at the moment
schools have pretty limited room for
maneuver they really have to follow
even though it's called guidance it's
pretty much an instruction
from public health england uh to to
follow these procedures
so it must be changed yes we'll keep an
eye on that one certainly as will all
the parents and children involved
and very quickly to the the metro and
this is a another idea for
for dealing with and living with with
covid business bosses to to get
quarantine exemption if they can
show that they will have significant
economic benefit to the uk
a good idea sonya i think it's a tricky
idea actually and you know we've gone
from this story
about um schools and whole bubbles being
have to send home
being sent home possibly not making the
best use of the testing we've got
available and then we've got this story
about senior business executives
being able to leave their quarantine
leave self-isolation for business
activity
i think first of all it sends the wrong
message we have these measures
because they're important from a health
perspective and i think if you allow
some people to break them but not others
um
that says to people well maybe you don't
need to stick by them anyway
i also think and you know lots of small
businesses have
protested about this you know why why
should it only be
um senior business executives and the
government has sort of proposed this
test
which is you know 50 percent more likely
chance
of creating 500 jobs in the uk how on
earth are they going to test that it
sort of seems like the thing that is
going to be used as a get around by
business people coming into the country
um you know they'll just sort of be able
to make it up on a form
and it it does have a ring of one full
rule for them
another rule for us sort of uh vibe
about it yeah yeah i can see how you
would say that uh isabel we'll talk a
bit more about this a little later on
for the moment thank you both sonia and
isabel